من رمال العلا تنهض قاعه مرايا تحفه فنيه
تتربع الاوديه الصحراويه وترسخ الدوره
التاريخيه للعلى باعتبارها عن نقطه التقاء
الحضارات القديمه على مر القرون هي اكبر
مبنى عاكس في العالم وفقا لموسوعه جنس فهي
مكسوره ب
9,740 مرايا عاكسه تعكس مظاهر الجمال
والطبيعه الخلابه للمدينه منذ اعوام تمضي
العلا في طريقها لترسيخ اسمها كمركز
الثقافيا عالمي يحتضن العروض الترفيهيه
والبرامج الفنيه والافلام والحفلات
الموسيقيه وكذلك اجتماعات العمل
والمؤتمرات وحتى حفلات الزفاف
ايه استضافت القاعه عدد من نجوم الفن
العربي والعالمي مثل
طنطوره 2020
والامريكيه لشاكيز في اول العام الماضي
واشهر مؤخرا وخلال ايام تصنيف حفلتين
للنجمه اصاله والنجم كاظم الساهر اما
المايسترو ايطاليا مغني الاوبرا العالمي
اندريا بوتشيلي فهو ضيف العلا الدائم يعود
في مهرجان شتاء طنطوره ليقدمه خامس حفلاته
في المدينه
[موسيقى]